hey everyone this is kevin from the
chest website that common pleased to
announce it on our website which if you
haven't checked out in a while you
definitely should the chess website that
comets got some really cool stuff we
just recently launched a new membership
section to the website it's pretty cool
if you haven't already seen it but in
the top right hand corner has your
username/password where you can log in
you can also click on this register if
you're not a member I know many of you
already are and then it takes you to a
landing page where it's going to say
okay go ahead and become a member right
away this video I kinda want to talk
about what are you going to get from the
gold membership and then what you can
expect from the YouTube channel one
thing you're going to get from the gold
membership is a lot more content so I
get emails every day YouTube emails
every day saying hey Kevin we want more
content we want more videos you know the
stuff you put out great we just want a
whole lot more of it and so that's
exactly what the gold memberships going
to provide you not only have we taken
all the material from the chest DVDs and
made it available on the website but
we're going to be adding new content
every week so if you've gone through the
website if you've gone to the YouTube
videos and you really enjoy them you
enjoy the learning this is going to be
really good for you because we're going
to be going more in depth into the
openings we're going to have a lot more
variations we're going to go into more
chess strategy we're going to go into
more tactical stuff into the endgame so
I really think this is going to be a
place where people can really take their
their chess game to the next level now
on the YouTube channel just won't let
everyone know we're still going to be
uploading new videos to the YouTube
channel so no fear is there I love the
youtube channel i love all the
subscribers and i think this is the best
channel out there but i don't let you
know more contents a lot more content
will be added to the membership section
on the chess website calm so if you guys
have any questions about the membership
or anything else feel free to reach out
to me directly via email it's the chess
website @ gmail.com a lot of people put
a comment or send me a message on
YouTube that kind of gets lost in the
mix but if you just want to send me a
direct email I can typically respond a
lot faster so hopefully you guys have
already become members if you haven't go
ahead and join enjoy the content if
there's anything specific you want to
see
since I'm going to be putting out a lot
more content I'm always looking for for
new ideas of stuff you guys want to see
be a really good chance that your video
will get made so looking forward to all
the feedback you guys have and I look
forward to all lowering its going to
happen again if you have any questions
feel free to reach out and i'll see you
guys in the next video thanks for
watching